what would the world Miss if there
weren't movies well I would miss a whole
lot
[Music]
movies are a spectacular translator
of shared Humanity across the globe
movies translate a very communal and
cultural language so we would be missing
out on communication in a big way we
would be missing out on cultural
education in a big way there are
sometimes people who don't know other
cultures unless they see them in films I
think Cinema in movies are windows to
different cultures different societies
we've been connected through Cinema
somehow and I think what films did for
me even America movies they showed me a
part of the world that I just wouldn't
have known and I feel that that
connection with the world it continues
to do that and I all my knowledge all my
connection to this world is through
Cinema and I know many others who know
me and my culture and my country it came
from watching movies if there were not
movies in the world there would be a
huge deficit a great lack of culture to
be shared if there were no movies I I
think the world would miss out first of
all on that communal experience the
world would miss communion communal
almost religious experience of sitting
together with a room filled with
strangers but you're all emotionally
connecting to the same experience movies
are experiences
they're not sedentary they don't stand
still when we go to a movie theater
where we're jumping out of our seat in a
horror laughing out loud crying next to
a person you've never met before I think
movies kind of give us that feeling and
that experience and so personally for me
I'd really miss that and of course if
it's in a movie theater then everyone
gets to do that at the same time and
that amplification of laughter and
crying and amazement is all the more
exciting there's also something very
concise about that period of time that
kind of 90 minutes to two and a half
hours with a story that transports you
for that fairly short period of time
with the beginning middle and end that
stimulates the imagination in a way that
is it's very very unique without movies
the world would miss empathy I think the
movies teach us emotional depth and
relatability and storytelling that no
other medium I've ever experienced does
the world would miss a Time of
transformation meditation space to look
inward space to heal space to law space
to be angry space to express ourselves
that we can choose at any moment movies
allow people to go into this weird space
that's between reality and dreaming the
suspension of disbelief that's so
beautiful and I can't really see any
other medium that lets you do that it
would be a world with yeah without the
possibility of escaping and following
someone else's life and echoing
something to take a distance from the
reality so it would be just the status
world if the world didn't have movies
be a sad place I feel like it would be
kind of sad there's the whole checking
out of your own life to watch a movie
but then also when a movie like moves
you or makes you think but then also
just entertainment too without movies
the world would miss the sort of
blissful one hour and 37 minutes you get
when your child gets engrossed in a film
and you can sit and have a cup of tea
you know not all of us want to go to
therapy but I can pretty much guarantee
that everybody wants to see at least one
movie in their life and I think that
those of us maybe that don't choose
therapy can find whatever you would get
from that kind of healing in a space
where you can just sit and watch a movie
and have someone tell you a story you
know whether we need a to laugh or to
cry we need places movies and Beyond
where we can see a piece of ourselves
maybe a piece of ourselves that we don't
know we need to see or we didn't know or
even a part of us but you know there's a
chance to make contact with people and
whether that's just through sheer
entertainment or the depth of a certain
piece you know I think it's about making
contact it's a very uniting thing a
movie and we would miss that
[Music]
foreign